فوضى عارمه تسللت من ليله هادئه شهدت عشاء
اخيرا جمع البرهان وحميدتي قطع خلالها
وعودا بحضور وسطاء امريكيين وبريطانيين
لمنع تدهور الامور بينهما نيويورك تايمز
التي نشرت التفاصيل ذكرت ان اليات كانت
تستعد للقتال اثناء العشاء حيث تدفقت قوه
الدعم السريع بهدوء لمعسكرات الجيش في
الخرطوم كما حاصرت قاعده مروي العسكريه
بدايه الخلاف بين الرجلين كانت نابعه من
قلق حميدتي حول اختراق الجيش من قبل
موالين للنظام السابق في حين بدات
المخابرات العسكريه باخبار المسؤولين
الاجانب بان حماتي حاول سرا استيراد
طائرات درون من تركيا لتعزيز قوته
العسكريه لكن سبب احتدام الخلاف بينهما
ارجعته صحيفه لمحاوله الاتفاق على دمج
القوتين في جيش واحد ما يعني حل الدعم
السريع وعندها سيكون حميتي الخاسر الاكبر
[موسيقى]